I am joined today by Carter Paige who is
the managing partner of Global Energy
Capital former foreign policy adviser to
then candidate now president Donald
Trump and also a central figure in the
Trump Russia investigation he's
mentioned a number of times by name and
this now infamous Christopher steel
dossier which we will we will get to
first of all thank you so much for
joining us Carter nice to speak with you
David I just one brief little correction
I was a member of the Trump campaigns
foreign policy advisory committee I was
a volunteer on that for a while I
actually never had any direct
relationship with then candidate Donald
Trump and I've never spoken with him but
certainly a you know a minor minor
clarification no doubt so I mean how did
you I guess that's a good place to start
how did you end up even as part of that
group that was offering that advice on a
volunteer basis you know I've been
involved in a lot of foreign policy
debates and projects throughout my life
I was you know I've been in fellow at
various think tanks you know spent
several years at the Center for national
policy in Washington so you know I knew
that obviously the the he was a
candidate and I believed that a lot of
things he was talking about in a foreign
policy context made a lot of sense and
so you know I knew some people that had
contacts with him so I I went ahead and
I volunteered in late 2015 early 2016 so
you were in other words you identified
aspects of his platform that appealed to
you when it comes to foreign policy and
so nobody reached out to you you you
sort of made the first step and reached
out through intermediaries to the Trump
campaign yes yep that's right
and what I've been and I was I was a I
was actually a
member of the New York delegation for
then you know while Senator McCain when
he was a candidate in 2008 so I was out
in the convention in Minnesota so you
know I knew various contacts through
that you know in terms of Republican
circles that was you know some similar
stuff which I had done and even though
it was on a volunteer basis in the sense
that that you weren't paid not everybody
who wanted to volunteer to advise on
foreign policy was welcomed right so
there were there was some reciprocity
there there was a certain point at which
the campaign said okay we're putting
together this group it's a volunteer
group but the idea that anybody who
wanted to volunteer would be part of
that group you're certainly not saying
that you were part of an established
group well you know the the term of
reciprocity is you know I think it
relates to mutual benefit right I mean I
I was just a volunteer and you know the
main benefit it was like a charity for
me right
I never very want to that eyes the Trump
Organization yeah you know not it's not
the Trump Organization you know again
there is a I apologize campaign yeah
exactly yeah interesting so let's talk
about the foreign policy elements of
trumps platform that appealed to you
that made you say this is somebody I
would want to advise on foreign policy
what was it that he was saying
particularly at that point in the
campaign that so appealed to you that it
motivated you to get in touch and say
here's where I want to volunteer you
know I think it continued to solidify
over time and I you know the one speech
I would refer you back to was I believe
it was April 27 2016 is a speech at the
Mayflower Hotel in Washington where he
kind of outlined the specifics of it and
I don't have the full document in front
of me but some of the main themes is you
know there's been a lot of disasters in
US foreign policy and the time has now
come to take a new approach try some
different different
strategies and you know he he alluded to
some of the wars that were that it
unnecessarily been created you know
particularly Iraq etc and you know some
of the relationships which had really
gone downhill significantly and let you
know one of them lips would be under
that umbrella you know well I think a
couple that he particularly highlighted
was or at least in one speech they of
meant one quote in the fairly long
speech may have mentioned was you know
major powers in the the you know p5
permanent five members of the UN
Security Council including China and
Russia and I thought you know that made
a lot of sense and your expertise is
really focused in Russia in a sense
right I mean I look back at your PhD
dissertation and a lot of the work that
you've done you lived in Russia for
three years so would you is it fair to
say that among those countries your
particular expertise and relationships
that you had bringing in were connected
to Russia or would you say one of the
other countries might be where you had
more expertise you know I would it
wasn't really relationships it's just I
think you know you you alluded to two
sides relationships and expertise yeah
yes I lived in Russia for three years
from 2004 to 2007 but you know that was
you know around a decade ago
right so I in the years since have done
a lot in the Middle East Africa Asia
across Europe a little bit in Latin
America and mostly international energy
issues related to the United States
where you know a lot of the shale
technologies and other innovations that
US entrepreneurs have been doing
particularly in the energy sector which
is my which had been my main specialty
you know can be a catalyst for
going back to your term reciprocity yeah
you know possibilities for mutual
benefit between the United States and
others so but to be clear and I want to
make sure I'm not misunderstanding when
you pointed out that there were that
there were foreign policy ideas that you
liked from Trump and you listed a number
of countries there where you have
expertise
you mentioned African countries and also
Latin America Trump didn't make
bettering relations with African
countries in Latin America a significant
part of his platform right it was really
of the ones you listed it was really
Russia where he was talking about it
well you know I think he's alluded to
you know I would encourage you to look
back at that Mayflower speech from April
2016 because it gives it a good sense of
the concepts he was really thinking
about and starting to move forward on
and I think it compares and meshes
nicely with a lot of the things he's
already done in his initial
year-and-a-half in office so I you know
I think there's a little bit of a
misunderstanding or I should say a
significant misunderstanding with you
know an overemphasis on Russia given the
conspiracy theories related to that but
don't be horrible just so our audience
understands when you say like conspiracy
theories related to Russia that's such a
term that can be used in so many
different ways what would be like an
example conspiracy theory about Russia
at least as it pertains to you maybe
since I'm only talking to you here not
you know other people well sure well
that's I'm happy to talk about it look
as as I wrote in my letter to director
then director of the FBI Comey in on
September 25th 2016 you know let's let
me see I have a copy of this yeah so as
I as I noted to him you know there was
this you know that you alluded to the
dossier the world premiere of that
dossier was
launched or shown to the public on
September 23rd 2016 you know an excerpt
from that which alluded to you know al
you know completely ludicrous
allegations that you know the DNC's
consultants had come up with that I had
I had met with the CEO of Rosneft and a
senior admission senior officer within
within the Kremlin during my July 2016
trip to to Moscow so the as I wrote as I
mentioned to then director Comey and my
first first sentence I said I wanted to
provide you with a few basic facts that
should help underscore what a complete
waste of time this witch-hunt directed
at me is right so I think you know it
really you know I don't I can only speak
for myself yeah that's all I mean you
know yeah most you know hmm
most of the people whose names have been
involved in this this ongoing saga you
know I never even spoke with or met in
my entire life well let's immediately we
can let's explore because our audience
might not have everything that that you
have in front of you or the awareness of
all of the details I mean just like as
an example when you testified before
Congress in November of 2017
you did say you met with Andre barinov
who's not the CEO of Rosneft but he is
the Head of Investor Relations right
that is accurate okay so look I mean who
who what's your favorite sports sports
figure my favorite sports figure I don't
I I have no idea I'm not sure what the
relevance is of that so you know let's
see you know who's the best who's the
top star in the Boston Celtics you know
if you meet if you have a car if you
walk by the the you know the TD Garden
the Boston Garden
sure
and you know talk to someone there I
mean to say that you are you know tap
some big conspiracy well but wait a
second call you know the owner of the
Boston Celtics etc I mean you know I
went so just to be clear you're alluding
to before I step back hold on if we can
Carter because I don't want I don't want
to get off on the wrong foot with you
I'm not alluding or implying anything
I'm just saying
five minutes ago you said it was alleged
you met with the CEO of Roth's NEFT and
that was you said it was ludicrous it
was a witch hunt etc what I'm saying is
okay you didn't meet with the CEO but
you did have it you didn't walk by on
the street you met with the head of
Investor Relations Andre Baranof true or
not true
I you know there was a big party we were
watching the Euro Cup you know I think
it was Portugal vs. Wales or something
like that
okay you know everyone is just so you
know I stopped by this party that was
organized by one of the big US
investment banks in Moscow with a ton of
people and yes I said hello to him there
okay
so you know it's completely apples and
Nords oranges that you know this crazy
conspiracy that this guy is offering you
know the CEO of this company is offering
me an 11 billion dollar bribe well but
hold on I'm not saying that right car so
I'm just trying to stick it I'd say I
mean that's okay let me tell you
something that I forget exactly who
asked me that question in that in that
testimony I you know it's been you know
17 yes yeah but you know the the the
implication which that individual asking
me to that question it may have been
congressman Schiff if not I believe one
of the other Democrats on the committee
is that you know maybe there's some
wrongdoing there or maybe there's some
shred of truth in this absolutely
ridiculous document known as the dodgy
dossier there no but so okay there's not
yeah sure fair enough so okay you did
say hello now you were asked during the
same testimony
we're sanctions or the privatization of
Rosneft brought up during that exchange
as brief as it may have been and you
said that Andrei barinov may have
briefly mentioned it so that's that is
more than just saying hello if he may be
briefly mentioned either sanctions or
privatizing Rosneft that's more than
just hello right so that I'm again it
doesn't seem is under dispute here okay
David if I asked you okay when you were
at the Boston Garden yeah you know
sitting at you know similarly watching a
game good if you were watching a game
there too
over two years ago mm-hmm I was this is
a great example I remember I did this
exact thing you're saying good ok so
when you when you were there and if I
find asking you a transcript of every
conversation you had you know and those
in that time and you're sitting there
yeah it's hard to remember and you know
all I said is I may have you know that
had briefly talked about this you know
thing that was in the news right you
know any sanctions is a driver of you
know I mean it's a significant
consideration in the in the economy of
Russia so you know I may have briefly
come up I mean that's the thing about
concerns people Carter is that we've
spent five or six minutes just on two
questions which are like did you meet
Ross Neffs Head of Investor Relations
and might sanctions have been discussed
and it's almost like you think that it
is actually a big deal because you're
saying so much as opposed to just
answering it and I think this is
sometimes in the other interviews that
you've done what I've perceived as
making people say what these seem like
simple questions why isn't he just
answering them because if it was no big
deal it doesn't seem like there needs to
be so much elaboration you know maybe I
just don't understand it no because it
because there's unfortunately David and
I you know I I haven't had a chance to
watch listened to your show but you know
I know that a lot of people there they
like to take a lot of things out of
context so I wanted to make sure
they're enough that you have the full
contact that's you know I mean just like
you can those those two those two little
topics you raised are absolutely
irrelevant particularly in comparison to
the highly relevant crimes against
American democracy that the DNC funded
through that you know million dollar
plus smear campaign which was totally
false as it relates to me when it comes
to that when it comes to attacks on
American democracy at this time speaking
only for yourself as Carter page the
individual do you believe the consensus
of the intelligence community that
Russia not only meddled in the 2016
election but meddled specifically to try
to help Donald Trump and defeat Hillary
Clinton or is that a finding that you
reject I have no evidence to support
that all I know from firsthand
experience and as we've seen through 400
pages of you know largely redacted
information that came out this weekend
you know the into u.s. intelligence
committee during that time when they
were you know working on those issues
and I was getting attacked by the DNC
mm-hmm there was a lot of government
collusion with political operatives you
know but what I know firsthand through
the evidence that I've very much you
know seeing them intimately familiar
with is that collusion between the DNC a
political operatives and the US
government their intelligence committee
the same individuals that you're asking
me to assess there was serious collusion
and they did engage in hacking but I
know that's very and I think we now have
it on the public record from Saturday
that they did engage in hacking against
myself so that you know I I don't I
don't really I'm not an expert in those
other topics David but I think what we
do know is there was definitely hacking
against me
so do you build either way and a way of
getting of the intelligence community
that Russia
to help Donald Trump you said you're not
an expert in that but what we have is
those are their findings do you have a
particular reason to disbelieve those
findings as my question I don't have
reason to disbelieve I think what I have
is you know I look back at a track
record when yeah the CIA and other US
intelligence community assets have over
the course of the history you know its
history the 71 your history of the CIA
yeah you know came up with these false
theories that let that then led to war
so most infamously with the original
dodgy dossier that's why you know when I
refer to the dodgy dossier of 2016 which
was used as a way of attacking myself
and the Trump Trump campaign but I'm not
asking is that the reason why I say that
is the 2002-2003 dodgy dossier was also
a PR campaign also from London which was
used to sell the public on a war with
Iraq and I you know all I'm saying is
I'm not willing to jump on any any
theories from the Intel community
particularly given the crimes that have
been committed against myself and other
other Trump movement supporters so you
know we'll have to see I keep an open
mind but what we consider what would you
consider as evidence to say okay Russia
did metal to help Donald Trump you know
look I mean if there's if there's strong
evidence on that you know I I just
haven't I haven't seen anything right
that any I think I think President Trump
made a made a good point in Helsinki
about the server right you know I mean I
think it's it's important that you have
to look at the servers and the fact that
there didn't even hand that over and
just used similarly DNC funded campaign
operatives to make that assessment you
know I I I know what other DNC funded
campaign operatives have done in terms
of election in turf
appearance with the misinformation
campaign but you know I don't have much
much insights about that yeah we're
speaking with Carter page we'll take a
quick break and continue with him right
after this we're continuing our
conversation with Carter page Carter I
know we have limited time so there's
just a few different things I wanted to
touch on and get your thoughts the
government claims you were an agent of a
foreign power is that a finding that you
reject accept or aren't sure in terms of
how that's being defined it's David it's
a finding that's just absolutely
hilarious when I read it I mean it's
just if you look at you know the
elements which they're using to come to
that conclusion yeah some fake news
reports I mean it's just it's just such
a it's just such a shame for you know
the the standards of law enforcement but
again I think what's nice about what
happened on Saturday is that they
started you know taking some steps
towards transparency so hopefully
hopefully as those hundred plus pages of
black lines are eventually revealed
we'll understand how that's much clearer
what I just don't understand and again
this might be my naivete and if it is I
you know I'm totally open to you
explaining it to me when you say that
that it's absurd or laughable or a joke
or whatever you were the subject of
government surveillance of an American
citizen that requires a very very high
threshold to even be allowed in our
justice system many of the people
reviewing those requests were Republican
appointees so how do how do you explain
that if there's just nothing there these
requests were approved and approved and
subsequently approved how does it happen
or am I just naive and I don't get it
well look I think you know a court is
given information right right and I
think it's you know it's it's fairly
common actually that a court is going to
use the information that's provided to
it right so there's this console
and I believe it says it directly on the
top of that application but it's ex
parte right which means you know
basically it's one one side is is
putting in this giving this information
without listening to the other side yeah
so you know I think that's exactly what
happened and I think as we've seen
through real hard evidence based on the
great work that various committees in
Congress have been doing to get to the
bottom of this yeah there was definitely
some political motivations in false
information that was given to that court
and I don't hold I don't hold anything
against those four Republican appointed
judges you know I have a similar case I
have a similar somewhat related case in
the US District Court for the Southern
District of New York and you know my
judge was given false information by the
US Department of Justice as well and you
know I understand you know I I
understand the reason why people assume
that the US Department of Justice is
going to do the right thing right
particularly you know some some judges
actually served as assistant US
attorneys or other you know DOJ
positions in their in their own careers
and you know it comes with the
assumption that their people are doing
the right thing right and I think from
that I think as we as we started to seen
see there's a that unfortunately did not
occur and that's that's the reason why
that happened why would they target you
with this with would this slanted
evidence and and concocting a storyline
to get a court to go along with it
though if as you say you were this minor
volunteer only guy who never met Trump
never spoke to Trump what why would they
say let's let's concoct a case against
Carter page why would they do that well
I mean listen I don't know that he
caught any of that testimony by one of
the FBI's HR professionals from a few
weeks ago yeah but you know I think
there's uh there's a lot
evidence of biased you know and so and I
have Incans to be here by Republicans
not you know no I'm talking about the
quote unquote secret society within the
FBI and you know people that said let's
stop the Trump presidency you know
that's that's what I'm referring to and
so I think there's there was definitely
motive and intent and you know we're
still in early days this is a I agree
with really part of a long saga and we
got a little bit of disclosure over the
weekend we'll hopefully get a fair bit
more as the rest of these documents get
disclosed but so far it's looking pretty
ugly related to the really illicit
intent of some people that are operat
operatives within the US intelligence
community so cars right there you've got
to go last thing I wanted to ask about
do you believe you will end up indicted
as part of this Trump Russia
investigation David I can't even imagine
anything that I would be you know
considered for an indictment for I mean
if I've never done anything wrong I've
been going to Russia for over twenty
five years first time you know in the
closing months of the Soviet era in the
summer of 91 nothing I've ever done in
Russia related to Russia was not only
you know nothing was illegal
nothing was unethical what I've ever
done over there so so you did nothing '
you don't believe absolutely not it's
impossible all right Carter page
managing partner of Global Energy
Capital I really do appreciate you
taking the time to talk to me I hope you
feel that I've been respectful I've done
my best not to interrupt I don't think
I've done any yelling so I hope that it
was the tone out it was night it was
nice to talk to you Dave it's my
pleasure okay I appreciate the time
thank you so much